this is dedicated to the [ __ ] that was
down from day one oh [ __ ]
[Music]
refills why'd you sleep in [ __ ]
[Music]
[Music]
[ __ ] with big dicks a cave and one
more second
are you [ __ ] kidding me geez up hoes
down if that [ __ ] can't swim
she's bounded risen
[Music]
oh [ __ ]
Monday night deep in the cloud of debt
the Voodoo Lounge Monday the 27th of
February rockin and rollin [ __ ]
myself and my trusted little [ __ ]
bodyguard the Jew of debt
aka krav maga suck my dick he I'm saying
if we go for another fun-filled [ __ ]
Monday night the [ __ ] is uncle grab the
drama gun hell yeah you know I'm saying
[ __ ] if you're under 18 hang up
now uncle Joey coming down the [ __ ]
Street [ __ ] Church coming at you
Larry's pills we got [ __ ] indicas
it's all over tonight there was no 200
milligrams so we got into indica 100
milligrams
you put those two good together [ __ ]
you grew up with don't even respect your
ass cuz time for the doctor to check
your head oh [ __ ]
not wanna slap the taste out your mouth
where's my man
poking land Vegas holding it down and
[ __ ] the security consultant just
another homicide get me so I can walk oh
[ __ ]
[Music]
it's a different color it's a different
world [ __ ] they're also dynamo boys
we [ __ ] them up baby
well the number one advertisers for
reefer out there why because we're
living it you see what we look like at
the end of these [ __ ] podcasts like a
tornado it is that's the gold Punk
[ __ ]
Bow Wow well upo would you be eight oh
[ __ ]
Bow Wow you'd be Oh your behavior in the
[ __ ] house look at him he's
puking already 10 years edibles he's too
[ __ ] making noises like I came with
his mouth you becoming some of these
mouths they make that creepy noise you
feel guilty but you don't give it you
ever come in somebody's mouth you feel
guilty but you don't you don't say
you're like [ __ ] there's a first time
for everything you shoot a load of that
[ __ ] protein powder coming in mouth
it's all over the ice cross for a second
I'm like what the [ __ ] did I get myself
involved with you don't jerk off for a
week you're give him a dose of that [ __ ]
then just choke and sucking swallowing
gagging who gives a [ __ ] you're the
Captain Kirk of this enterprise anyway
where's trumps nephew eh
[Music]
step on up oh [ __ ] it's gonna be a good
night I can feel it
you smell that fart Lee I fathered about
a half hour ago hasn't gone nowhere
between that the pot smoke is
cultivating the fun smoke it's keeping
it right make it one up got cheap in
your ma and your fix got to fit with my
balls on your tonsils with my balls on
your tonsils are you [ __ ] kidding me
these [ __ ] dudes what they started is
tremendous Martin Luther King would be
[ __ ] proud as a [ __ ] a
movement spotty Gotti oh [ __ ] - my White
Sox hat [ __ ]
oh yeah break out the reefer go to
Grandma's valium I don't give a [ __ ]
it's Monday night you wanna start the
week off with a [ __ ] bang
[Music]
pop star oh [ __ ]
[Music]
that bro is in the haha yeah
[Music]
yeah
easy easy easy can either big fat day
day dig yeah Welbeck want to be a [ __ ]
oh [ __ ] well the best [ __ ] arms of
all time right here
[ __ ] snoop and Dre right here [ __ ]
Danny Brown don't [ __ ] around when he
brought this the wu-tang we got a ton of
[ __ ] hand you wanna make noise make
noise I make a phone call my [ __ ] down
here like the guy debord
are you [ __ ] kidding me [ __ ]
Andre
[Music]
hey if you want to walk on ice you might
as well deathly ready for the bonds of
death rolling in my six folk with all
the biggies saying oh [ __ ] oh yeah oh
yeah
just smoke the [ __ ] thing will you
before I put a [ __ ] lie then this
bomb here here we go don't worry my head
matches the red light that's right
don't worry about the red light yeah
bong is for Jesus let's do this [ __ ]
[Music]
oh [ __ ] look at them taking it deep into
the realm you see his eyes and read
right in front of him you see his eyes
turn red in front of them the [ __ ] you
think look at the [ __ ] you think we're
dealing with you think I'm [ __ ] you
[ __ ] you know you people of my
heart come on up listen get one of those
brooms and tie it with your clothes and
just walk on the railroad tracks and
come on out to California let's do this
once and for all
come on out here get the job at the
beach surf live you're [ __ ] drink
you're living in some [ __ ] town you
don't want to be in I've been there I've
been there
you don't want to be there you look
around you get [ __ ] sick even though
you got nothing going on even though if
you've moved down here you'd have
nothing going on at least you'd be close
to the beach you'd have your little
medical marijuana license you know
saying you get a job but Trump chasing
Mexicans on rollerskates whatever the
[ __ ] you need to know everything works
out brother you gotta make the first
effort we've smoked the dope we [ __ ]
around in but eight come on down to the
Voodoo Lounge every single day
[Laughter]
rolling in my six-four I'm gonna use
them more dustman no use live buds in
there that won't get clock give me a
week or two and I'll figure it out it
gets going it already has pain no
[ __ ] I'm a seventh grade reject
[Music]
[Music]
that's right just like that people huh
you know I don't know what you expect
it's just Monday night listen we're
trying to get the party started
whatever you do you don't want to do is
none of my [ __ ] business let's
pretend you don't want to smoke reefer
maybe you want to do a [ __ ] glass of
wine hey uncle joy in here the judge you
know I've done some creepy things myself
break the monster oh [ __ ]
[Music]
I had open the door you gotta see this
office it's awful this two guys two
people thought we don't [ __ ] around
though I have what other people will
bring it into the different hills here
we're taking it to a different [ __ ]
Embassy
[Music]
some good night people don't switch the
channel
don't turn the channel it's gonna get
deep in this [ __ ] trust me you
know me dog on Mondays I go a little all
out because it's the best day of the
week and my world one day is the best
day if you don't have a good Monday your
whole week goes to [ __ ] you get a flat
tire on a Monday you don't wanna had a
flat tire to Mondays agar didn't let it
bother me because it was Monday and I
looked at there's a cost to doing
business
that's it they say somebody's shooting
your sister I'm saying it's the cost of
doing business you fix it and you move
on to the next one I'm an old man
you know what man I'm in the mood for
one of my favorite albums of all [ __ ]
time this guy he is a bad [ __ ]
trust me I'm telling you guys just white
dude right here Eric Clapton and the
sound Slowhand
this is uh this is one of my all-time
favorites I don't know why even like IRA
Clapton sings and you know me between
the anthem cocaine and between the
anthem snowblind how much smoke my god
but this comes second to none if you're
gonna snore the line stones out of
respect
don't let me know I don't wanna know
your snoring if you're smoking blow some
smoke into the lens and let's mix the
[ __ ] spirits up this party ain't over
yet we got two different types of weed
eight different types of edibles and
number endurance and we got nobody and
we got nowhere to go
nobody to see and establish so you
pulled in on a good night tosser get
down on the ground cocaine oh [ __ ]
[Music]
do you not do cocaine it's a brilliant
[ __ ] song
the one after this more brilliant and
the one behind that's even more [ __ ]
break okay no [ __ ]
[Music]
oh [ __ ] we think you're [ __ ] with
people it's Monday night I lived in my
mother's house
I would play Earthman and flop fire Led
Zeppelin the stones [ __ ] get get to
the ayazad I was strong [ __ ] here at
the age of 13 already look Bob Marley at
these [ __ ] if you're gonna get
down get down to the ground if not go
hang out with your [ __ ] friends at
Starbucks if you're gonna come hang out
with Uncle Joey you better bring the
[ __ ] reefer endurance and the balls
and don't forget Doug Benson's new show
what Mike what premieres tonight I was
gonna go down there with Lee but I had a
podcast what are you gonna do how to do
some of the family at 6:30 but besides
that we'll be back coming at you we're
gonna rock the road so they stop a
little bit we got a big podcast night
we're just going acapella tonight it's
the last podcast of the mother we got
eight this month and nine next
it's gonna give me a good [ __ ] March
so you got a great month plan for you
you know us bad we put a heart on the
table to say [ __ ] my house and he's
so don't gonna listen to [ __ ] it night
we're gonna go what are gonna turn up
the bachelor suck my dick
[Music]
oh [ __ ]
what's with the white hat Joey what the
[ __ ] it's Monday baby a little something
for my beeps up there you gotta keep the
Hat view it can be put no black hat on
his [ __ ] this brings you bad luck I'm
gonna battle I've had enough bad luck
growing up it's time for a new [ __ ]
lucky it where's the candle that we
blown candles look at this [ __ ]
smoked in here tonight
what is that we do with people you want
to [ __ ] around around somewhere else
[ __ ] if this is scary to you go booklet
bucket I don't give a [ __ ] who's rated
[ __ ] it off X was smoking there we go
you look wonderful tonight are you
kidding me Eric Clapton just lullaby on
you that was slow and then he comes at
you with [ __ ] lay down Sally do I look
like a lay down Sally you you [ __ ] get
your life together we'll be back in ten
minutes go to youtube.com slash Joey
Diaz /c / Joey peers as youtube.com
slash c / Joey Diaz ready dummy grab a
pen real quick I'm not gonna give you a
number
grab a bat comes up I'm talkin to you
get anything I don't give a [ __ ] in your
girlfriend's [ __ ] home or time killer
[ __ ] youtube.com slash c / Joey Diaz you
see how we do it
thank you for [ __ ] coming on and
smoking a few numbers of young people
Joey I'm an old man I'm an old [ __ ]
bump me understand but we do this
together we have a good time we had a
few [ __ ] last you let a little bit of
my [ __ ] with musics all about when music
was [ __ ] music today I'm gonna talk
about a little podcast and let his
skinny video live from Oakland and 77
and break it down for you what I see not
what you just see you see a bunch of
white people jumping up and down playing
the guitar there are drugs I don't see
that I see something more powerful we'll
talk about on the podcast I love you
[ __ ] Lee tell these
[ __ ] something and even if it
started back and angry that's right
[ __ ] this is a journey ain't no
race [ __ ] wash your [ __ ] we'll be
back in ten minutes
[Music]